- [Instructor] We're told
that point P was rotated
about the origin (0,0) by 60 degrees.
Which point is the image of P?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out.
All right, now let's think about it.
This is point P.
It's being rotated around the origin
(0,0) by 60 degrees.
So if originally point
P is right over here
and we're rotating by positive 60 degrees,
so that means we go counter
clockwise by 60 degrees.
So this looks like about
60 degrees right over here.
One way to think about 60 degrees,
is that that's 1/3 of 180 degrees.
So does this look like 1/3 of 180 degrees?
Remember, 180 degrees would
be almost a full line.
So that indeed does look
like 1/3 of 180 degrees,
60 degrees, it gets us to point C.
And it looks like it's the same distance
from the origin.
We have just rotated by 60 degrees.
Point D looks like it's more
than 60 degree rotation,
so I won't go with that one.
All right, let's do one more of these.
So we're told point P was
rotated by negative 90 degrees.
The center of rotation is indicated.
Which point is the image of P?
So once again, pause this video
and try to think about it.
All right, so we have
our center of rotation,
this is our point P,
and we're rotating by negative 90 degrees.
So this means we are going clockwise.
So we're going in that direction.
And 90 degrees is easy to spot.
It's a right angle.
And so it would look like
that and it looks like
it is getting us right to point A.
So this is a negative 90 degree
rotation right over here.
Gets us to point A.